[Music]
so the reason that I'm so passionate
about conversation and meaningful
communication is because of this thing
called the connection crisis and I am
NOT being hyperbolic when I call it a
crisis so ARP did a study in 1970 and
they found out that 20% of their members
identified as being lonely they did that
same study again in 2010 the number had
more than doubled to 45% 45% of their
members that were identifying as lonely
so the social survey came out a few
years ago and it found out that the most
common response when people were asked
how many friends do you have wait for it
zero zero
that number has tripled over recent
decades imagine going through life
without a single confidant and this
dearth of relationships is not just
making a sad it's literally making a
sick it is killing us because what
happens when we have weak social ties we
have increased inflammation it decreases
the body's natural immune response there
was a recent meta-analysis of 300,000
patients and it found that having weak
social ties was as harmful to your
health as being an alcoholic and twice
as harmful as having obesity so these
wild things are happening but so often
people are left to their own devices to
figure out how to communicate how to
connect you know we spend 15 years
studying something like social studies
and we don't even spend 15 minutes on
social skills and communication is the
fundamental building block of creating
these important relationships which are
so important for our personal lives and
also our professional success so that's
why we need to be intentional about
communication because with a little bit
of practice and a little bit of focus
anyone can connect more deeply with the
people they meet and the people they
love and when you think about that again
it's like when you don't have friends
it's like that's what opens you up for
extremism
it's said when you don't belong you will
do anything to belong you know what I
mean and so that's why again is
providing frameworks for people to
really connect is such a vital thing
you
[Music]